the Joe Rogan experience but your
simulation hypothesis we if we're in it
it's running now is it running and we
independently interact with the
simulation or is the simulation
introducing ideas into our minds that
then come to fruition inside the
simulation is that how things get done
like if we are in a simulation right and
if during the simulation someone has
created a new iPhone like why are they
doing that if other other people in the
simulation or is this simulation
entirely unique to the individual is
each individual involved in a different
coexisting simulation right so they the
I think the the kind of simulation that
it would be clearest the clearest case
for why that would be possible would be
one where all people would be simulated
that you proceed and each brain yeah
that is it because then you could get
the realistic behavior out of the brain
if you simulated the whole brain at the
sufficient level of detail so everyone
you interact with is also simulation
well that that type of simulation should
certainly be possible then it's more of
an open question whether it would also
be possible to create simulations where
there was say only one person conscious
and the others were just like simulacra
yeah I like that they like they acted
like humans but there's nothing inside
right so these would be in philosophers
parlance zombies that is like a
technical term but it means in in in
when philosophers discuss it's somebody
who acts exactly like a human but with
no conscious experience now whether
those things are possible or not is an
open and question do you consider that
every when you're communicating with
people the ever stop denying deliberate
I mean it's a card to me but not not not
record I don't know yeah does it
everybody but does it ever get to your
head were you like this might not be
like this person might not be a real
person this might be a simulation right
I mean I guess there are two things to
says one is that you probably have some
probability distribution over all these
different kinds of situations that you
could be in maybe all of those
situations are simulated in different
frequencies and stuff different numbers
of times that is so there would be some
probability distribution there that
would be the first thought that in
reality are always kind of uncertain the
second would be that even if you were in
that kind of simulation it might still
be that behaviorally what you should do
is exactly the same as if you were in
the other simulation so it might not
have that much day-to-day implications
do you think there's psychological
benefits for interacting with life as if
it's a simulation
no I don't think that would be an
advantage I mean maybe maybe this in
some case re what an alleviation of
existential angst yeah maybe but who
knows if it could also I guess if if if
you sort of interpret it in the wrong
way maybe needed to feel more alienated
or something like that I don't know but
I think to a first approximation the
same things that would be work well and
make a lot of sense to do in in physical
reality would be also our best bets in a
simulated reality that's work it's
really weird like if it's a simulation
but you must behave in each and every
instance as if it's not if you know if
you were given a you like if you had a
test you could take like a pregnancy
test when you went to the CVS and you
know you you pee on a strip I tells you
guess what Nick this [ __ ] isn't real
you're in a simulation a hundred percent
proven absolutely positive you know from
now on from this moment on that
everything you interact with
is some sort of a creation it's not real
but it is real because you're having the
same exact experience as if it was real
why do you proceed yeah I I think that
might be very subtle reprioritization
that that would happen what would you do
right personally well I I don't know the
full answer to that I think there are
certain possibilities that look kind of
far-fetched if you are not an
assimilation that become like more
realistic if we are like it mean so so
one obvious one it's like if you in
simulation could be shut off like if the
computer where the simulation is running
is if the plug is blown right right and
so we think physical universe has been
normal and I said it can't just suddenly
pop out of existence there's a
conservation of energy and momentum and
so forth but a simulated universe that
that seems like something that could
happen it doesn't mean it is likely to
happen or it doesn't say anything about
what time frame but at least is like
interest as a possibility where it was
not there before other things as well
become more maybe similar to various
theological possibilities that like
afterlife and stuff like that and in
fact it kind of maybe through a very
different path leads to some similar
destinations as as as people through
thinking about theology and stuff have
arrived at in in that that would mean
it's kind of different I think there is
no logically necessary connection either
way but there are some kind of
structural parallels analogs between the
situation of a simulated creature to
there you know simulators and and I
created entity to their crater that that
are interesting although kind of
different so so that might be kind of
comparisons there that you could make
that would give you some like possible
ways of proceeding it seems like
paralysis by analysis so you just sit
there and think about it like at least I
would
yeah I would almost wind up not being
able to do anything or not being able to
act or move or think well that seems
kind of likely to be suboptimal right
suboptimal for sure yeah
[Applause]